THEY SEND THEIR DUMB NUMBER ONE
DIPLOMAT INTO A VERY IMPORTANT
MEETING IN NEW YORK.
JOHN ROBERTS JOINS US FROM THE
NORTH ONE.
>> Reporter: JUST MOMENTS AGO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO ISSUED A TWEET SAYING,
LOOKING FORWARD TO MEETING IN
NEW YORK.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO THE
COMPLETE, VERIFIABLE AND
IRREVERSIBLE DENUCLEARIZATION OF
THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
THEY ARE PROCEEDING AS IF IT IS
IN PLACE FOR JUNE 12TH.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MET WITH
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
TODAY.
A STRATEGY SESSION AHEAD OF
POMPEO'S MEETINGS IN NEW YORK
WITH NORTH KOREAN VICE PRESIDENT
KIM JONG-CHUL, A PRELUDE TO THE
POSSIBLE SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG UN
POSSIBLE SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG U
KIM JONG UN.
>> WE ARE CONTINUING TO PREPARE
FOR THE MEETING BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND THE NORTH KOREAN
LEADER.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAYS, IF IT
HAPPENS, WE WILL CERTAINLY BE
READY.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE AS BOTH HIS
TEAM'S DISPATCH TO SINGAPORE AND
THE DMZ HAS BEEN ENGAGING WITH
NORTH KOREAN DELEGATION.
>> THE ADVANCE TEAM LED BY
DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF JOE HAGAN
MET WITH THE NORTH KOREAN TEAM
IN SINGAPORE EARLIER TODAY.
THE U.S. DELEGATION LED BY
AMBASSADOR KIM MET WITH
NORTH KOREAN OFFICIALS EARLIER
TODAY AND THEIR TALKS WILL
CONTINUE.
SO FAR THE READ OUT FROM THESE
MEETINGS HAS BEEN POSITIVE.
>> Reporter: AS HE TOURED HIS
PRESIDENTIAL SPORT AND FITNESS
EVENT TODAY, HE TOOK ANOTHER
SWING AT HIS ATTORNEY GENERAL,
JEFF SESSIONS, AFTER CONGRESSMAN
TREY GOWDY SAID THIS MORNING HE
UNDERSTANDS THE PRESIDENT'S
FRUSTRATION THAT SESSIONS
RECUSED HIMSELF IN THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
>> IF I WERE THE PRESIDENT AND I
PICKED SOMEONE TO BE THE
COUNTRY'S CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER, AND THEY TOLD ME LATER,
OH, BY THE WAY, I CAN'T
PARTICIPATE IN THE MOST
IMPORTANT CASE IN THE OFFICE, I
WOULD BE FRUSTRATED, TOO.
THAT'S HOW I READ THAT.
SENATOR SESSIONS, WHY DIDN'T YOU
TELL ME THIS BEFORE I PICKED
DEAL?
HE COULD HAVE PICKED SOMEONE
ELSE.
>> THE PRESIDENT TWEETED TO
GAUDI'S ENTIRE QUOTE ABOUT
PICKING SOMEONE ELSE FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL, ADDING IN THE
WORDS, AND I WISH I DID.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
TODAY THAT SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER IS LOOKING INTO A
MARCH 17 MEETING THAT TRUMP HAD
WITH SESSIONS AT MAR-A-LAGO, A
MEETING IN WHICH HE REPORTEDLY
ASKED SESSIONS TO REVERSE HIS
RECUSAL.
SOURCES WITH THE INVESTIGATION
TELL FOX NEWS THAT MUELLER NEVER
SPOKE ABOUT THAT.
BUT IN HIS LIST OF QUESTIONS FOR
THE PRESIDENT, MUELLER WAS
CLEARLY INTERESTED IN THE ISSUE
ASKING, WHAT DID YOU THINK AND
WHAT DID YOU DO REGARDING AG
SESSIONS RECUSAL?
AND WHAT DID YOU TRY TO DO TO
GET HIM TO CHANGE HIS MIND AND
REVERSE?
WHILE THE PRESIDENT WAS IN
LOCKSTEP WITH GAUDI, HE WAS OVER
GAUDI'S ASSERTION THAT THE FBI
DID NOTHING WRONG.
BUT THIS DISPATCHING A
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANT TO GET
CLOSE TO SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE
PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN.
>> I'M EVEN MORE CONVINCED THAT
THE FBI DID EXACTLY WHAT MY
FELLOW CITIZENS WOULD WANT HIM
TO DO WHEN I GOT THE INFORMATION
THEY GOT, AND THAT IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> Reporter: THE PRESS
SECRETARY TODAY SAID IT, NOT SO
FAST.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT STILL HAS
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THE FBI ACTED INAPPROPRIATELY,
HAVING PEOPLE IN HIS CAMPAIGN,
AND CERTAINLY, THE PRESIDENT HAS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE OVERALL
CONDUCT OF THE FBI WHEN IT COMES
TO THIS PROCESS.
>> Reporter: TO PROVE THAT
JUST ABOUT ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN
HERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE, REALITY
TELEVISION STAR KIM KARDASHIAN
STROLLED ACROSS WEST EXECUTIVE
DRIVE AND INTO THE WHITE HOUSE
LATER THIS AFTERNOON.
SHE'S HERE FOR DISCUSSIONS WITH
JARED KUSHNER ON PRISON REFORM
AND ALSO ADVOCATING FOR A PARDON
FOR A GREAT GRANDMOTHER WHO HAS
BEEN IN PRISON ON A NONVIOLENT
DRUG CHARGE SINCE 1996.
ALSO SPOTTED AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
RUDY GIULIANI, WHO TOLD THE
PRESS HE HAS BEEN CONDUCTING
PRESS
PREP SESSIONS LOOK AT THE